شهد عام 2016 تقاربا سياسيا بين حزب
العداله والتنميه وحزب الحركه القوميه اثر
محاوله الانقلاب الفاشله صيف ذاك العام
الهدف الاقرب انذاك كان خوض الانتخابات
المرتقبه والتي اوصل خلالها الحزبان
مرشحهما رجب طيب اردوغان للرئاسه ونال
اغلبيه مقاعد البرلمان
دعمت الحركه القوميه مساعي العداله
والتنميه في التحول للنظام الرئاسي
فاجتمعت اصواتهما في البرلمان للدعوه
الاستفتاء شعبي عام 2018 ولد تحالف
الجمهور رسميا حين خاض الحزبان انتخابات
اثمرت فوز اردوغان بمنصب رئيس الجمهوريه
بعهده رئاسيه وفق النظام الجديد واغلبيه
برلمانيه اما الانتخابات المحليه عام 2019
فخاضها الحزبان في قوائم منفصله
وتنافسا خلالها في بعض الولايات غير
الرئيسيه
التحالف وان كانت سمته قوميه محافظه الا
انه توسع في انتخابات 2023
ليضم حزب الرفاه من جديد الذي يقدم نفسه
وريثا لفكر رئيس الوزراء الراحل نجم الدين
اربكان وحزب الاتحاد الكبير اضافه الى
حساب داعمه ابرزها حزب الدعوه الحره او
الهدى حزب اليسار الديمقراطي حزب الطريق
القويم وحزب تركيا الكبرى تغطي الاجنده
الانتخابيه للتحالف اهتمامات ابرزها
معيشيا يركز التحالف على دعم ذوي الدخل
المحدود من خلال دعم تكاليف الخدمات اضافه
لوعود بالسيطره على مستويات التضخم ماليا
يفضل التحالف ان تبقى القرارات المتعلقه
باسعار الفائده على الودائع من اختصاص
المصرف المركزي لكن باشراف السلطه
السياسيه
اجتماعيا يدعم التحالف اجراء تعديل دستوري
بشان الحجاب لحمايه الحقوق والحريات
الاساسيه وقانون الاسره بتعريف واضح بشان
تشكيل الاسره من جنسين مختلفين
دستوريا يتمسك التحالف بالنظام الرئاسي
ضامنا للاستقرار السياسي اما على مستوى
السياسه الخارجيه فيتمسك التحالف بعلاقات
طيبه مع المحيط الاقليمي لتركيا واخرى
استراتيجيه مع الغرب كجزء من النتو
والاستمرار بلعب دور وسطي بين الحلفاء
الشرقيين والغربيين